I love that you came here tonight thank
you so much that really does mean a lot
well I'm actually I came onto your show
to plug my appearance on your new show
it's gonna be on tonight we run a clip
of our banter just for a second and you
just saw that was it that was it you
know we have a strong connection you
invented you coined the phrase Coco Coco
that he made Coco you did that I think
was about ten years ago now it's stuck
that was all you yeah it has followed me
it will follow me to the grave it is
because I couldn't remember your name
but I was trying to work out like that
bit fans can flash it to each other like
in cars yeah on the freeway yeah they
could just do Coco right oh cool I
thought at some point I could do Coco
but then it looks like Coco wouldn't
smell right and also it is dangerous
flash shines for youth gangs you lost
the band there's an abandoned internee
I'm I'm on work release Andy has never
been paid 70 bags they told me that you
were forced to play football against
your will is yes that's true story I
don't know if that if I would say that I
wasn't as into it as other people were
little lovers what you're like the
middle linebacker and in between plays
you just lay on the grass and pull
I was the third man point where this
sweetened bowl where your helmet
backwards is it a joke because I don't
care